the
likes
tell
Just to say
[Silence]
and they are like
So,
is
[Silence]
and
change.
When it comes to
when it
minor sins, major sins, they are of
different intensities.
Some sins are more stubborn
and being removed a stain. And some
are looser. They just need a quick wash.
Others need to be scrubbed. Others need
to be soaked overnight. others you can't
remove it without something major and
those are major sins right and so
for this reason we have over overlapping
acts of worship that expedate just like
when we wash our clothing we have over
overlapping
cycles of wash what doesn't get this
stain out the next one will get it like
a filter and whatever doesn't get that
one the next batch of worship will get
it. And major sin is the same thing.
There are some sins which are very
intense and there are some sins which
are less intense and so the expeation
is less. And likewise
the repentance
because a major sin in order for it to
be expedated in order for it to be
erased a person has to do what?
for a major sin. There has to be
there has to be repentance for that.
And so merely doing good deeds will not
patch that up. It has to be repented
from.
And so for this reason, our prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
has informed us of the great mercy of
Allah that he has made these acts of
worship overlapping
so that these acts of worship will act
as a filter to our hereafter
that any of us that goes through this
barrage of of worship and his life will
come out the other end without any sins.
hopefully without any sins to account
for.
Subhanahu wa'ta'ala. and
subhanahu
and
[Silence]
F my guy. How you doing? I see your dad.